Hey wise crack jared again and today
we're talking about everyone's favorite
drug.
Addled Gandalf,
Alan Moore.
Alan Moore has authored many of the most
acclaimed comics of all time including
watchman miracle man and the killing
joke and like the joker and Batman and
that story more straddles the thin line
between genius and insanity.
Oh,
decided it might be more interesting to
actually terrified them.
Boy going completely mad and declared
myself to be a magician.
He calls himself a ritual magician,
not the kind that pulls Ravitz from
hats,
but these Stephen strange variety that
consults grimoires and conjures demons
seriously at first glance.
Much of what more means by magic seems
more like the superstitions of a man
hitting his corn cob wizard pipe a
little too hard,
but if we take more seriously for a bit,
there's a pretty fascinating philosophy
at play here.
So what can we learn from a guy who
claims he tried to end the world?
Well,
we're going to have to dive into a
little known and even less understood a
cult tradition known as hermeticism
welcome us.
Wise crack addition on the philosophy of
Alan Moore.
Today's topic is magic real.
There's a ton more to cover however,
so if you want more,
let us know in the comments.
But first a quick shout out to our
sponsor hymns who allows men to turn to
science rather than magic when it comes
to hair loss.
Hims is a personalized and private
online way for men to get access to
medical grade products and connect with
real doctors.
They offer solutions to treatable
problems like hair loss and adult acne,
so you can hopefully look like Alan
Moore well into your adult years.
They're also your one stop shop if
you're looking for help in the boner
department,
they've got science based treatments for
Ed and since 18 to 40 year old men are
less likely than any other group to
visit the doctor or pharmacy,
which is where you get your medicine.
I'm told Hams lets you chat with real
doctors all online so you never have to
leave the house again.
And because hymns offers generic
equivalents to name brand prescriptions
and direct shipment,
you're getting major savings that you
can use for anything.
Hims is offering wisecrack viewers a
full month trial of their comprehensive
haircut up to a $67 value for just five
bucks while supplies last head do for
him.com/wise
crack or click the link below to get
your discount today and now onto more.
More is a student of Hermeticism,
which is less a religion with set
doctrines and more a set of interrelated
practices and principles hermeticism.
His goal is to seek understanding of the
world through three methods,
Alchemy,
astrology and fear g.
The first two are familiar enough,
but the third theory is basically the
process of achieving spiritual
perfection with the goal of growing ever
nearer to God.
Hermeticism is largely based on the
teachings of the Corpus Hermetic up by
the mythical Hermes Trismus justice.
He's a mixture of Hermes and thought
both the Greek and Egyptian gods of
language and wisdom respectively to
more.
This mixture of language and
understanding is the heart of magic in
his upcoming the moon and serpent bumper
book of magic more defines magic as a
purposeful engagement with the phenomena
and possibilities of consciousness.
So what does that mean?
Essentially Morris saying that what we
call reality can be broken up into two
categories.
Who material and the immaterial.
The material is all the physical stuff
matter and energy,
space and time,
fundamental forces,
all that,
but we never experienced those things
directly.
Photons hit our retina,
pressure,
waves,
impact or eardrums.
Those signals get sent to our brains and
based on that limited sensory
information,
the brain makes a mental model of what
it perceives the external world to be
like.
That mental model is the immaterial to
understand how the material and
immaterial affect each other in profound
ways.
Let's think of watchman more had an
ephemeral idea in his head for a story,
but it wasn't until artist Dave gibbons
gave the idea form by penciling in those
panels that it achieved a four.
Moore's intangible thought had a
tangible effect on the arrangement of
the atoms that became watchman.
The opposite is true as well.
You're picturing in your mind's eye,
doctor Manhattan statuesque and
uncensored Azor Fallis for no other
reason than because I mentioning it,
the physical sound of my voice has
altered your perception by conjuring
that image in your mind.
I cast a genuine spell to more.
That's all magic is magic bridges the
divide between the material and the
immaterial art language symbols.
These are the real wizards wants per
more magic is intrinsically connected
with art,
language and consciousness to the point
where these four things almost become
different aspects of the same
phenomenon.
This same principle as seen in the
rabbit duck illusion.
At first glance you see either a rapid
or a duck.
Just because someone's mind initially
interpreted as duck doesn't mean that
meaning is fixed.
All it takes is for someone to tell them
it's also a rabbit and all of a sudden
it changes right before their eyes.
It's storytelling as spell craft.
Just as storytelling can be used to cast
illusions.
It can likewise dispel them as an
anarchist.
More counts money among the more
destructive illusions to ever distort
mankind's collective conscious.
When miracle man tasks himself with
making earth a utopia among the first
things he does is abolish money.
Suddenly announcing money is a promise
to redeem the cache of every bearer for
its worth in gold or merchandise and
empty promise.
Should we all demand at once redemption
of our coins,
we learned such wealth does not exist.
Monies imaginary real.
If we believe in it,
come summer money won't exist,
but then it never did.
This method of magically altering
something by changing the way you think
is most clearly seen in promethium.
A notable example happens when
protagonists has a rematch with the
demon king as modus initially and co are
set on slaying asthma day in anger,
but it's only when they accept that so
called demons are just a part of human
nature.
The worst parts that as modus is
appearance shifts to that of a human.
He explains,
approached us with fear,
with hatred and revulsion and we will be
fearsome,
hateful,
and while approaches humanely and with
respect and we will be human and
respectable for the magician,
expectation creates perspective.
Even doctor Manhattan is a magician in
this sense.
He externally appears as an ageless aqua
marine adonis with alopecia solely
because this is how he internally
perceives himself.
So if a sufficiently compelling story
can magically change our perception of a
single phenomenon,
what happens if we tell a story that
tries to account for all the phenomenon
in existence more does exactly that in
promethium telling a story about
everything as a spell to change our
perceptions about everything.
Of course,
we can never quite wrap our heads around
the infinite expanse of all space time,
but we don't need to.
One of her medicines,
his most famous principles is something
called macrocosm and microcosm expressed
in the Maxim as above.
So below this principle presumes that
every level of reality reflects every
other like an infinite fractal or like
how everything wrong with youtube can be
distilled down to Logan,
Paul and all the worst things about
Logan Paul or echo throughout youtubes,
other channels.
Being able to understand one part of the
pattern allows you to better understand
the whole and in turn move from lower
levels to higher levels.
With promethium.
The entire structure of the series is
deliberately based upon a specific
structure that repeats at macro,
cosmic and micro cosmic levels from
entire neve existence to each individual
soul,
the Kabbalah tree of life.
For more the tree of life is the roadmap
to all reality,
including our inner lives.
At the bottom rung is mere perception.
Seeing the rabbit or duck above that is
imagination.
The ability to make mental models of
things not directly apprehended with our
senses.
Above that is our capacity for art and
language.
You build lead to tie ideas to sound
symbols,
pictures and stories and above that our
capacity for emotion and reason
respectively.
At the macroscopic level,
the physical universe is the basis
sphere of the world.
Soul.
Above that is everyone's collective
unconscious and at the very top of the
tree is what early her medicines called
the all the one God.
That's why premia is 32 issues long
corresponding to the 10 spheres and 22
paths of the tree of life added
together.
The story itself ends at issue 31 so he
wrote a 32nd issue itself,
32 pages with each page expounding upon
one of the paths.
Thus,
the issue was a deliberate microcosm of
the series as a whole and the series a
macrocosm of the issue or as above.
So below another hermetic principal used
by more is solve at Coagula or separate
and combined basically breaking a thing
down into its component parts to better
understand how the whole fits together.
Dr Manhattan's are in watchman is all
about him learning solve at Coagula.
When we first meet him,
he expresses an understanding of the
first half separate better than anyone
else.
He's detached from humanity because he's
mentally broken humans down into their
base components,
not unlike his father did with watches.
His breakthrough on Mars is learning not
merely to break humans down into
abstract arrangements of atoms.
In my opinion,
the existence of life is highly over
right,
this phenomenon,
but
rather to conceptually recombine and
perceive them as holistic.
Four dimensional objects solve at
Coagula is seen even more clearly in the
sixth issue of promethium.
Sophie finds herself inside humanity's
collective imagination and faces off
with writer Marto Nip Tura the pseudonym
for a writer of the promethium character
as a writer,
nip turns power over the land of fiction
is nearly absolute.
Sophie is only able to defeat him by
understanding that nip Turo was the
collective pen name of various
novelists.
Cut Down to is separate unique styles.
So if a compelling story can change
one's view of the world,
what happens when a story is so complete
a model of the world that it changes the
perception of our entire species for
more.
When everyone's way of viewing the world
one way ends,
the world ends in promethium.
This is exactly the task that's sophie
has given Margaret,
one of the prometheans before Sophie
explains,
humans are amphibious.
That means they live in two worlds at
once.
Matter and mind promethium makes people
more aware of the fast,
immaterial realm.
Maybe tempts them to explore it.
Imagine if too many people followed
where she led.
It would be like the great Devonian leap
from C to land to entity slithering up
the beach from one element into another
from matter to mind.
More believes that it was through a
similar leap from matter to mind.
Vet Our ideas about the world began in
the first place.
Representation allows for the
origination of verbal language with this
sound or this collection of mark.
Somehow also standing for that buffalo
over their language is the necessary
precursor of are apparently unique form
of consciousness.
Humanity's first purposeful engagement
with the phenomenon and possibilities of
consciousness.
Out of this engagement sprang almost
full blown the entirety of human culture
writing,
painting,
Song,
Usic Theater,
science,
medicine,
and even politics.
And so in the same way that this idea of
the world began,
it also ends in the series penultimate
issues.
Sophie succeeds in bringing about the
apocalypse by explaining to everyone the
same hermetic principles we've been
talking about.
Everyone now perceives the immaterial
and the material worlds as equally real.
But while permia bringing about the
world's end within the comics more was
contemplating how our world will end in
a similar fashion in the 12th issue more
uses the Taro to trace the history of
the world from the initial quantum
vacuum and God big bang,
the universe into existence all the way
to the coming leap to expanded
consciousness more places his own doom
say cock quite close to midnight,
like his character roar shack carrying a
sign that says the end is nigh.
How near riding that issue in 1999 more
predicted the end of the world as we
know it would occur in 2017 when the sum
total of our knowledge would double at a
rate of every half second with so much
new knowledge coming so quickly,
our old ways of understanding the world
wouldn't be able to keep up and we
naturally need new ways of understanding
the new world.
Those of you alive back in 2017 may
recall that the world did not in fact
come to an end,
but before the year came and went more
himself tried like his character
promethium to herald the apocalypse.
At the hour heat appointed in September
of 2016 on the eve of his prophesized
worlds in more released his magnum opus
Jerusalem.
If promethium was a spell,
he has to magically change the minds of
individual readers.
Jerusalem was the ritual he performed to
bring about worldwide revelation as more
himself a test rather than performing a
ritual to produce a successful book.
The book itself is the 10 year ritual
working that is intended to have a
certain,
hopefully beneficial effect upon the
consciousness of its readership.
Jerusalem seems to me to be my most
sophisticated and complex,
magical working thus far and certainly
the most ambitious in its aims.
Ambitious in its aims is an
understatement.
More rights in such a way that the
reader experiences the higher states of
consciousness that the narrative is at
the same moment describing not this
similar to the way the heptopods
language in a rifle profoundly affects
lois lane's perception of time.
This is especially evident in a chapter
told from the perspective of Lucy,
a joist during her confinement in an
asylum in employees,
the same linguistic style found in her
father's novel,
Finnegan's wake abounding in puns,
portmanteaus and the alogia slums in
order to replicate Lucy as condition
more explorers.
How those exhibiting certain forms of
insanity might be closer to perceiving
external reality than those who are
deemed quote sane in watchmen.
Doctor Manhattan perceives every moment
of his life simultaneously a far
different perception than quote sane
individuals.
But more like Einstein regards time as a
stubbornly persistent illusion.
So the fact that Manhattan is not taken
in by this delusion of time makes him
more sane,
not less.
It's we who are deficient for perceiving
only the now rather than being able to
gaze upon the past,
present and future.
Like we might take three dimensional
plane in order to get us in the habit of
perceiving the dimensions which we might
not initially perceive more employees
solve at Coagula to language itself.
Taking apart the written word into its
base components,
separating phonetics,
how vocalized words sound from Graph
Fenix,
how written words appear more writes
dialogue as a series of words that look
like Jibberish,
but when read phonetically makes sense,
more forces the readers who read
multiple layers of meaning in every
word.
For example,
if you read this aloud,
you get the phonetic dimension.
Her father in his time maintains that we
are in a universe composed of four
dimensions,
only three of which are naturally
visible.
This phonetic dimension is only one side
of the techs and if it's the only part
we observe,
we miss out on its other possible
meanings.
The jibberish is full of double
Entendre,
like spelling dimension in a way that
resembles dementia or universe in a way
that resembles loony more teaches us to
read with more dimensions than we
normally perceive in a text about how
the universe has more dimensions than we
normally perceive.
It's explanation and example at the same
time magically changing how our mind
models of the world by changing the
language with which our minds construct
that model.
Of course,
even if everyone in the whole world did
read Jerusalem and have their minds
expanded by more,
it doesn't necessarily follow that.
We'd make the great leap from the murky
waters of matter to the solid land of
ideas and imagination.
While more may not have managed to bring
about his revelation in 2017 given his
status as the most influential writer in
the history of comics,
his literary efforts are likely to
remain influential for centuries.
So is magic real?
If more is right,
it's at least as real as our
imagination.
This is prometheans revelation that ends
the world.
Speaking not to any of the characters in
the comic,
but to you the reader.
I'm an idea,
but I'm a real idea.
I'm the idea of human imagination,
which when you think about it is the
only thing we can really be certain
isn't imaginary.
See,
I'm imagination.
I'm real and I'm the best friend you
ever had.
Who Do you think got you?
All this cool stuff.
The clothes you're wearing,
the room,
the house,
the city that you're in,
everything in.
It started out in the human imagination,
your lives,
your personalities,
your whole world,
all invented,
all made up and there's nothing here but
a funny little twist of amino acids
playing a marvelous game of pretend to
that list of cool stuff that imagination
has given us.
We can certainly add the highly
imaginative works of Alan Moore.
Thanks for going down this weird and
wacky rabbit hole with us and if you
want to spend more time with the wise
crack crew as we continue to go down
these weird and wacky rabbit holes,
then I recommend punching our logo in
the face to check out the whys cast
channel where we have video,
podcast,
special clips,
and even a new vlog format coming soon.
So if you like what we do and want to
see more of us subscribe to wise casts
and I'll see you on the other side
piece.